hello welcome everyone to ed talks with
khan academy
i'm christine decervo the chief learning
officer here at khan academy and today
i'm excited to talk to mark steinberg
who is the k-12 education program
director at the walton family foundation
so we're looking forward to that
conversation to talk a lot about covid
response and education and philanthropy
as we
think about what lies ahead for our
schools
after the results of
all of this copen
experience that we've all been through
sal is going to be back on friday he is
his guest will be chess world champion
magnus carlson so look out for that
as we think about coven we also want to
recognize some of the
sponsors who have stepped up and helped
us
make it through some of the the combat
times here at khan academy including
bank of america at t google.org novartis
fastly and general motors
thank you for your support
and with that let's dive right in
so first let me say welcome
thanks for coming and joining us today
it is it is a pleasure kristin to be
with you i am no
international chess champion but uh i'm
an education advocate par excellence and
i'll do my best to keep up
awesome
we all have our own strengths
so i mentioned to you off air i am i
love chest though uh so i will be i'll
be tuning in on friday you can be sure
and uh hopefully we'll go through some
openings or i don't know
engage yeah
i can't wait to hear hear that
conversation i think it'll be good
but for everyone that is here today
uh first let's just kick off and tell us
a little bit about yourself tell us how
you
ended up in this position and and you're
a bit of your path to get here
great well i'm happy too and and
in all seriousness thank you for having
me and thank you uh kristen to you to
saul and to the entire khan academy
family and team for the amazing work you
guys have done for so many years and
especially frankly over the last year
i think we'll wind up talking a bit
about that um in our time together
uh i
my path into
uh this role um
runs through the classroom um you know
right out of college i took a job
teaching um i'm i am i work for the
walton family foundation which is of
course based in bentonville arkansas i
am based in brooklyn and you know i much
of my much in my life my professional
life before coming to walton was in
service public service to this city as a
teacher right out of college uh as a
school leader a school founder i started
a high school
uh that i led for six years in the bronx
the bronx lab school
and then as a policy maker serving as a
deputy to chancellor klein in the last
term of the the bloomberg administration
so
so my you know i cut my teeth
um
as a pedagogue um
as a pedagogue working with a group of
students uh then with the you know you
know the school community and then uh in
service to new york city
um at the policy level
all of which have been a great great
preparation for this work with with uh
with the waltons um thinking about
education on the national stage
that's great
tell us just a little bit about founding
a school what was
what prompted that and what were you you
know thinking as you were thinking this
is a different experience or a new way
of thinking about school that you wanted
to take well
uh
you know it it it came from
a lot of a lot of it came from
a desire to have impact
um which was
is a little bit in my my dna
of sort of just being a doer um
kind of the the the
the match that that lit the fire as it
were uh for the school was my teaching
experience where i
sort of observed
um what educators many educators in your
community i'm sure feel um
incredible passion and energy and
potential of my students
um who probably taught me a lot more in
my years of teaching than i especially
those early years and i was
able to
to teach them
a sense of um
wanting
uh to build a school community in the
bronx especially that
that would be their first students and
help them meet their full potential and
and i think fair to say you know
starting teaching in the mid 90s in the
bronx um
a sense that we could just do better
uh a sense that schools were you know
were too often mixed about how they were
making decisions
um you know my school had three
principles in the you know the
the years i was there
so i experienced kind of on the one hand
this radical sense of potential for my
students who were just waiting in a
sense and and so i experienced both the
the wonders of that but also
the tragedy of that and felt that coming
uh coming you know there was a brief
interlude of grad school between
teaching and coming back to start the
school and i felt like
you know that was my calling i was i was
called back to you know you know to come
and try to craft something very
different um for you know high school
students i have a high school student of
my own who's walking into the room right
now um to visit his dog so don't you
like during
coping times yeah
yeah so hopefully yeah just keeping it
real for your viewers
um
the
this was also
at a moment closing the door
um okay
so is that a moment of remarkable kind
of policy
opportunity and a window of leadership
for new york city and its schools that
um you know i view a singular where
um
you know this the city's mayor and
chancellor
looked out at the at the landscape of
options and saw a cohort of schools that
had been failing students
for decades with graduation rates in the
in the teens and 20s um and basically
like
sick and tired of being sick and tired
and and looking for a round of
entrepreneurs to come in and think about
um a better path forward
yeah that definitely makes sense tell me
a little bit more about your role now at
the foundation and what that what that
entails what you do
well um
you know education's been a huge pillar
of
the walton family's philanthropic
interest
for 30 years
long before i got her and you know far
into the future
the family has has cared about this work
it's been the center of their
their philanthropic strategy
and that's really about um
a belief
first that education matters
that it is a central pillar
and helping
communities and and families and
students
live you know a self-determined life and
reach their full potential
um
and and a sense that so much of
what we can do is unlock the potential
both of
you know both of students and of
educators you know the the
you know the center of our strategy is
looking to teachers and looking to
educators looking to folks who know the
work the best
because they've done it and they've
lived it for a round of ideas
about how schools and classrooms can
work differently and so it's really been
the privilege of a lifetime to be
in a position to help um you know help
the family do its work
so tell me a little bit about what you
do so are you looking for
opportunities and and groups to
that you want to support what is that
like
yeah
well so we
what we
we are focused on
um
you know i would say a few key pillars
one
at the center of our work is um the
school and a quality school so a lot of
what we've done over the years and what
we'll continue to do is
find educators who have ideas of a
different kind of school what the school
could be whether that's a new charter
school a new public school
but elevating talented educators who
have in mind to
to start either to start a school or to
become school leaders and find their
path
to school leadership of course
you know that that is important
it requires cohorts of educators folks
who want to come into the profession so
investing in pipelines into the
profession
investing in community advocacy
and community voice
so to help communities uh develop a
vision and a and
a voice about what school can look like
how school
uh can meet them meet the needs of their
community which i think in this moment
of of all moments
um
is is critically important
um and and i think you know
you know also critical at this moment is
an investment in kind of what the future
of
learning can look like with what the
future of the classroom can be so a deep
focus
um we apply a deep focus
on um kind of broadly innovation and
teaching and innovation and
um
models and what the future can look like
lots to follow up on there um so let me
uh start with though thinking about you
said you know especially in these times
um and as we think about as covid
hit
what did you see as you know how you
could bring your resources to what was
happening as covid started just about a
year ago this week
we started to see a lot of impact
well i mean
our first instinct
i mean look i think like everybody it
took us a minute to kind of understand
the scope of this
um
the fact that we are now
look i hope
at the end and i hope past the point
about you know
um
questions like how many days a week are
kids going to be in school or when can
we get kids back into the building i i
mean i i'm i'm i'm living in new york
city and like what i can report to your
listeners that in this town
it's it's we're sort of seeing the other
side of that discussion
um
but at the beginning i think we all
thought maybe like you digging that this
was going to be then
muddle through for the rest of this week
so that we're now talking we're deep
into the second full square
um of confronting this is just
just michael
our
you know our our i i would characterize
the work we have done
in the wake of covet in
parts
um
first
was look i'm just trying to be a
resource for leaders in
the folks we've worked with and in the
cities in which we've worked so
providing some flexibility around
resources and even some additional
resources
dollars
so that
school leaders can
do the things that frankly that people
were privileged to work with we found
them doing like delivering
books and materials delivering meals
home
making sure that you know families in
their community had
had you know hot spots to get online
when instruction
moved online so just the first order of
business for us was just
providing
extra resource to meet the moment
um and there was no
we we knew we could never do everything
but we needed we needed to do something
so that was
that was yeah
hot spots that's been for us because
obviously we are an education technology
um organization and
we struggle with this you know part of
equity is actually
getting the resources to the students
who need it most and
we you know are are always thinking
about
gosh there's this whole group of
students we can't reach because they
don't have that connectivity so have you
guys been working on that issue
we have and and that's sort of a bridge
um to the second big part of what we've
done and that's sort of thinking about
through an advocacy lens
thinking about how we can address the
needs that became so clear and acute at
the moment and at the top of that list
was access
access to access to um
you know to
clear
broadband and and kind of the you know
connectivity and and even the rare
um i think we've got good news coming on
this
uh christian i think um my understanding
is that the legislation that is making
its way to the president's desk um
includes some
some good news for families that are
living on the wrong side of the digital
track so that's
encouraging and we're we're ready to
celebrate that
it it's also i think you'd agree
you know a moment to just pause
and sort of acknowledge that there are
still families
in this country
that have you know it's not as they
don't have access to high-speed internet
they have lived through the last 12
months without high-speed internet
um
and i'd like to think that there is um
i'm thrilled that there's a solution and
and you know we know that just because
there's federal resource for this uh the
problem is not solved there's a lot of
work to do to get this
you know to get those dollars to the
right places and to build solutions that
are permanent
um i guess my reflection on this is that
you know
um
this this experience has
has
raised awareness of problems like this
and i think
uh generated a lot of public will to
solve those problems i guess what i want
to i want to express to your viewers is
i i hope it's
i hope it's a i hope we can hold on to
the urgency we feel um
that that we don't
sort of get back to life as as usual
and forget the urgency of many of these
challenges which frankly before covet
um
you know well let's just say they
predated covet and we tolerated them
before
so
so as we move back to life uh life as
usual i hope that we can hold on to you
know kind of the urgency of solving some
of these big problems
definitely
so thinking about that future
what do you think
as we as we look forward are some of the
things that you see
may change perfectly in education from
where we are now
well i i think i make a few points here
i i do think that this is a moment to
grab for a different kind of future in
the classroom
and you know
that future has always been something
we've been able to talk about as long as
i've been in the work
from when i was a classroom teacher to a
school leader to a policy a policy guy
um but it has always been just over the
horizon and i would i would credit khan
academy and saul and all of your your
collective work is helping us kind of
like see it more clearly
but i think you'd agree it's it's it's
just been like right over the edge
actually for more years than i want to
say yes it has always been right over
the edge
well so i mean just generally speaking
this needs to be a moment when we we
grab it
and we we grab it and run toward it
where where
uh like we understand it not as
something nice to have
but
a necessity
for the equity agenda for the work of
like honestly lifting up the teaching
profession i mean you've seen the data
kristin the you know
we'll see if it holds but right now one
in five teachers
are telling us they're not coming back
to the classroom and that's already
like on top of a you know a moment for a
decade when when you know we're you know
one of the critical challenges is
attracting and retaining
um quality talent in the classroom so
we've got to make the profession more
sustainable
and um
got to help teachers be more effective
we got to we got to like lift up student
learning like there are big leaps
forward
um that need to happen
if you know if we're going to help
schools meet their promise
and you know software-based solutions
need to be a part of that they
absolutely and and i think you know i
think a close observer might say that
despite
some great progress over the last decade
it just hasn't happened
um in some ways teachers are telling us
that the profession has gotten harder
not easier so this is a moment when
we've got a going to reach over that
horizon
you develop solutions look to teachers
and entrepreneurs to help us
uh figure out what those are and and
bring more coherence to the the teaching
and learning experience so that that is
i mean i'm i'm
i'm speaking maybe more in generalities
than you'd like me to but like that's
that's our thesis and we're excited to
do our part
yeah so we've got a question that kind
of leads to that from facebook lori beth
ford gerald says
please define success for students
teachers in schools and i think that's
an interesting question to think about
what does you know if we talk about
wanting to see the you know changes in
teachers and students and what is
success how do we define
success well i mean
for us that success is about um
uh yeah this idea of self-determination
that school is going to prepare you for
you know to lead the life you want to
lead
and i think that's got to be at the at
the
at the student level we've got to be
focused on skill development
and developing kind of
habits of mind and and um
and
content mastery and
basic skills in numeracy and literacy
uh and critical thinking that prepare
students for
um can you hear me sorry
yeah you're good okay good sorry um
so
so
skill development and and mastery
content you know content mastery um i
think we also need to we need to attend
to the social and emotional health of
our of our students as well
i will say
that
you know the last year
has been a
a massive reminder and i'll say more
candidly a setback
for the children in this country
and we're going to have to we're going
to have to confront that as a country
and put
front and center
kind of the
emotional well-being of students when we
think about success now i'd like to
believe that
that these things are not mutually
exclusive
that the idea of developing hard skills
um that we know are important
for a life well lab for for this idea of
self-determination
um of being literate and numerate at the
highest levels
are are actually quite consistent with
the idea
of like emotional wealth of health and
well-being
um so i think i think when i think about
student success those are things i think
about
when i think about teacher success i
think about moving educators
to a place where they are focused
exclusively
on human-centered
elements of pedagogy
where we are
developing tools in the classroom
that work harder for teachers that make
their their jobs and their lives easier
um that get them
faster
to the work
of supporting student learning
which is why the teacher joins the
profession
so if we can do that they're more
satisfied they're more effective their
time and energy are more focused and
centered on the things that are of
highest
of highest value
and i think we're i think
if we're doing that at scale we're
lifting the profession up
um so
those are those are the first thoughts
that come to mind
yeah
you talked about self-determination for
students doing what they want to do i
also know that in
some of the things that you talk about
in terms of the types of innovations
you're looking for you talk about
community driven or community demand
um
how do you
bring that into the work that you do and
you know how do you hear the community
demand or listen to
it
small conversations
that are
that are like kitchen table
um discussions with folks
who have the most at stake who are
closest to the action
um
in their communities whether it's you
know whether it's in the south or in the
pacific northwest um and and and we know
there are a lot there's lots in common
across communities but every
you know all of these all of these
problems are super local so for us
this has been honestly about building a
muscle that is
um
that is a listening muscle
um which doesn't mean that we're leaving
our experience and our points of view
behind the things that we've learned
um we're in fact bringing those with us
into these conversations but we're you
know this is about i mean this is
classic
organizing and i will i will say um as
someone who's been philanthropy a little
while
um
well i said it you know a skill that
we've got to build uh it is not the
natural instinct of philanthropy to
listen first and act second
um
so
so that's you know
that's the idea
yeah
sort of sort of a ghost blow to go fast
kristen
yeah yeah that makes sense
i know that when you listen sometimes
you hear lots of conflicting viewpoints
like i think the school reopening has
been a case in point about that where
different people have really different
views and think about things in
different ways and you have different
stakeholders with different interests
um do you how do you navigate that and
kind of try to bring people together
i mean yeah i mean this is the this is
the trick and uh and the risk
you know
a lot of a lot of good examples of
well-intentioned change agendas that
that fall apart because they reach for
you know absolute kumbaya consensus and
that's you know that can't be what this
is about i think what we
you know this is about balancing the
patience of listening with the urgency
of action
um
and
um
you know an orientation
on a set of a set of problems that you
know
uh
that can be solved and that left
unsolved have a kind of cascading
pernicious effect
um
so so it's it's not
this is not an exercise of you know
everybody standing in a circle holding
hands and agreeing on everything
this is about
you know building an understanding of
the local nature of the problem
in this case you know in your in your
instance you know how do we get kids
back into school and if we can't how do
we how do we do everything we can
to
make sure that on the other side of this
we're not confronting and a a
a learning loss challenge that we can't
surmount
broadly i mean that is a micro version
of the problem that walton has been
solving for 30 years how how can we get
a better school and a better educational
experience in reach for more students in
this community we're we're clear that
that's our orientation and we're looking
for
um
we're looking for local partners who
have frankly better ideas about how to
do that
um because they're they're close to the
problem and they've lived it in their
homes and and uh we hope they we hope
we hope they can invite us in um to be a
resource if they they try to solve that
problem
great so
you talked about you know innovation and
community tell us things that you're
excited about or some innovative things
that you're seeing or working on that
excite you
well i'll say um
let me let me
you know
let me start with
assessment and and
like you know
i you know kind of
accountability i i hesitate to mention
the words like it's like a four-letter
word these days
um
you know
i
i'll just name this as a
a vertical that requires new thinking
and and and like a deep attention to
what comes next
and i
what i'm very clear on
that is frankly keeping me up at night
and so many advocates up at night is
just how
perilous the moment is for the country
as it relates to data collection and
student performance
i mean
even even
absent covet you know we're confronting
um
you know decision points at the state
and federal level of where whether we
should be in the business of collecting
students data that allows us to have
kind of comparability to know how one
set of students is doing relative to
another set of students
and then covet happens and we're now
looking at two consecutive school years
where we're not sure what kind of data
we're going to have
i i believe that is a
massive threat to the equity agenda
but which you know there just aren't
many other threats that rise to that
level of urgency
this to me is a
is an innovation challenge
we are having a fight in this country um
in in the four corners of our little
k-12 community christine
whether we should test
and
and
that's you know that's an important
discussion that i hope lands in the
right place
what we
i'll be doing is thinking about
knowledge
to capture what students know
and to capture
you know the full spectrum of the things
we care about
um as it relates to student performance
and this gets back to your question
earlier the listeners question their
their social and emotional health
their content mastery their skill
development
this is
imagine a day
are we back
apologies for technical difficulties
all right
i can
all right
hello
i can hear you can you hear me
everyone this is uh yeah 2021 live
streams
okay can you hear me all right good good
that's slime
we're just about a time so i think we're
going to leave it there apologies for
the last a couple minutes of technical
difficulties here to all those folks who
are listening mark thank you so much for
joining us and thank you for the work
that you're doing to support learners
and learning in these times
great thank you kristin
thank you
goodbye to all of our listeners and we
look forward to
seeing you on friday
you